it was what the u.s called a righteous
strike a necessary act to protect their
own troops
now they accept the only people killed
by this drone attack were a family
desperate to escape
the explosives they thought were in this
car are likely to have been water
bottles the target identified by
intelligence as an isis facilitator
actually a long-time aid worker waiting
for a visa
i am now convinced that as many as 10
civilians including up to seven children
were tragically killed in that strike
moreover we now assess that it is
unlikely that the vehicle and those who
died were associated with isis k or were
a direct threat to u.s forces
i offer my profound condolences to the
family and friends of those who were
killed
these are the victims an extended family
of three men and seven children one of
them just a toddler the u.s will now
work on facilitating compensation for
their surviving relatives
the strike was initiated at a time of
incredibly high tension in kabul after a
suicide bombing at the airport killed 13
u.s military members and scores of
afghan civilians
but this tragedy is likely to provoke
further anger in a city already reeling
with feelings of betrayal by the u.s and
allied forces
they knew immediately that the drone
strike had been an awful mistake
this is the code of bugler neighborhood
and we live here a rocket came and hit a
house and six or five people died i have
nothing else to say we are distraught
president biden had initially hailed
this as a success evidence that the u.s
could carry out over the horizon strikes
from outside afghanistan after the
latest in a long history of u.s drone
strikes hitting the wrong target he will
have to consider what next for this part
of the country's defense strategy martha
kelner sky news washington dc